[Musik]
sebastian lege zaubert einen perfekten
gulasch geschmack fleisch braucht er
dafür nicht und auf das verpönte wort
geschmacksverstärker kann er auch
verzichten den fleischfans schmeckt ein
etikettenschwindel der zum kleinen
einmaleins der lebensmittelindustrie
gehört das ist kein fleisch das
geschmacksverstärker drin und sowas
darfst du nicht alle das ist nichts für
hunde bei uns menschen sieht natürlich
anders aus wir brauchen diesen
intensiven fleisch in geschmack mit
hilfe einer alten wäsche schleuder
demonstriert lege woher das fleisch
aroma kommt er vermengt ganz normale
back hefe mit ordentlich salz und etwas
wasser der aktivator ist natürlich
zucker der erweckt die hefe kulturen zum
leben sofort beginnen sie sich zu
vermehren
gut so denn lege hat es auf die
eiweißverbindungen in den hefezellen
abgesehen würzig schmeckt die pampe noch
nicht dazu braucht es erst die schleuder
und eine improvisierte heißluft quelle
[Applaus]
turbogang und hitze sollen dafür sorgen
dass die eiweißmoleküle der hefezellen
zerbrechen und sich in geschmacksstoffe
verwandeln
äußerlich ist der erfolg erkennbar wenn
die suppe dickflüssig und dunkler wird
falls die maschine so lange durchhält
naja was für eine sauerei
vielleicht hatte ein bisschen geklappt
weil das geheimnis das sieht ganz gut
aus
das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht
durch die wärme hat sich die farbe
verändert ist eine tolle konsistenz das
zeug schmeckt tatsächlich wie
fleischbrühe selbst die chemische
zusammensetzung kommt einer
konzentrierten bouillon recht nahe
experiment geglückt schmeckt original
wie hefeextrakt
in der industrie wird hefeextrakt
eingesetzt um bei würzigen speisen am
fleisch zu sparen
funktioniert das auch mit unserem selbst
gebrauten und wie weit kann man es
überhaupt mit dem geschmacksverstärker
treiben
[Musik]
ich habe immer was ganz feines
zubereitet gepumpt mit ein bisschen fx
traktors meiner werkstatt mal sehen ob
mir hier eine auf die schliche kommt das
überhaupt kein fleisch dabei ist heute
serviert sebastian läge ein kräftiges
gulasch allerdings mit soja
fleischersatz und hefeextrakt stadt
schwein oder rind werden die
testpersonen den schwindel bemerken
haben wir euch sagen guten appetit
vorausdenke die auch schwein tippen aber
geschmacklich kommt es ihr der wind
bringt
ok also schwer einzuschätzen das ist
schon mal sagen was sagen sie ja im
flash ist es nicht weil das hier etwas
trockener ja ich würde dann auch sagen
schon eine flanke kein testesser
bezweifelt bisher das fleisch im gulasch
ist nur die sorte will sich nicht so
recht bestimmen lassen
[Musik]
du kannst du nicht erklären
okay das wusste vom geschmack kann ich
nicht wirklich zu ihm okay wenn ich sage
dass das gericht komplett fleischfrei
ist würdest du mir das glauben
sie betreuen aber jetzt nicht
wiederholen ich hätte das niemals raus
geschminkt das ist aber so aus als wenn
es mithilfe extrakt gehen sogar billige
soja brocken als gulasch durch ein trick
mit dem sich kräftig sparen lässt der
gute herzhaft fleischige geschmack mit
der brise hefeextrakt haben wir nicht
alle aber die meisten leute hinters
licht geführt viele haben gedacht das
ist ein kräftig gekochtes gulasch da
kann man mal sehen was so eine kleine
brise zauber pulver auf dem glauben
alles anrichten kann
doch der hefe trick sorgt auch noch für
einen etikettenschwindel denn
hefeextrakt enthält vor allem eins
bluttat chemisch identisch mit dem
verpönten zusatzstoff das heißt überall
wo hefeextrakt draufsteht ist in
wahrheit der geschmacksverstärker drin
klingt nur besser und ist völlig legal
ich drehe die packung um und lese
hefeextrakt naja ist ein natürlich
erzeugt geschmacksverstärker es ist
nicht schlecht ist aber es bisschen
schmal auf der grenze gefahren die
aussage weil am ende des tages würde
auch geschmack mit intensiviert glutamat
kommt übrigens von natur aus in vielen
lebensmitteln wie tomaten oder hartkäse
vor schädlich ist der stoff erst in sehr
hohen dosen
doch wenn ohne geschmacksverstärker
draufsteht und trotzdem hefeextrakt rind
steckt ist das ziemlich unfair
vor allem gegenüber kunden die
ausdrücklich auf glutamat verzichten
wollen
achtet ihr auf geschmacksverstärker und
konservierungsstoffe in eurem essen sagt
es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips